yeah welcome to this video and play just
one guitar yeah
played a number of times already let's
play ready for a change
one of my more normal openings that I
also playing over the bachas at least
them once in a while yeah this is the
ready gambit we're white um gives away
the c4 pawn and usually doesn't get it
back but he allowed me to get it back
doing for Bishop to b2 92 because Knight
c4 is a good good option the knight on
c3 isn't really going anywhere okay
maybe B form as an idea so I can prepare
that and now Knight to c4 yeah but not
what I dunno
now I'm getting one of the bishops I
think otherwise I take a five
yeah maybe black like and I can't just
take it takes you fall
he goes Bush up c7 I just take it okay
so he's giving up this mission I don't
mind that at all yeah because now I'm
getting a default let's just check very
briefly that I'm not over looking
something no I don't think so if he
takes Knight takes gives me some
dominance in the center with the e4 pawn
on the post I've got two bishops on
their ideal positions on b2 and G - yeah
this is sort of the dream position of
the red team at the 8th you have this
extra center phone and have nicely
positioned bishops map like it's a very
bad shape here at least are
strategically it's um maybe not falling
apart quickly but what is his idea yeah
I'm going f4 and f5 if he allows me to
do that and very often this is not so
easily playable because of the dark
squares but now the dark square bishop
is gone so every fibre some sort of the
normal way to go okay I think I can gain
a temple on the Queen
not sure them threatening yep 95 is a
threat
and no f4 yeah keep it simple and play
aggressively this if fibers have moved
to meet
ya know I can I can win material and I
will can take here and play you six this
gets into this f5 f5 walk okay he can
avoid material losses if he moves with
the bishop somewhere like c8 but then I
have a fight with with an overwhelming
position yeah he sort of stepped into my
bread and butter kind of position also
can see that the time spent if I play an
opening that I don't know I spent much
more time and the reti is a regular
opening of my my tournament games black
resigned yeah it's just a piece and a
terrible position the thing is I think
really it started with with the snide c4
but here he needs to probably make a
precautionary move like this for example
so that after here he can he can protect
he five just one idea something like
that in the game it he is he needs to
give away one of the bishops and this is
already something you don't want to do
maybe I probably would have taken here
not yeah not lightly but what can you do
like something like this
probably I would have tried white is
better anyway it's just those two
but this this really this is really a
big mistake because I get exactly the
game position by force he has no way to
get out of this end and here
yeah now this this steamroller and I can
defend more accurately now but it's it's
very tough the cop is on more than one
paul h here without white having an
extra for the aren't yet that it's
winning the c6 idea the only thing he
could could try this but yeah this is
terrible
and system so the enormous bishop here
yeah an opening an opening mishap here
yeah thanks for watching